so how important is hydration for more
types of strategies would you advise
your players to adhere to to ensure that
you start the game and a hydrated steer
a hydration a big focus and would be
encouraging fluid intake and we'd be
using science in sports electrolyte tabs
just quite a little bit flavor to the
water and encourage the players to drink
without hydration and your tablets and
you what I think that definitely has an
impact because you can get more tired
cramp up so I said hydration are not
important before who came it's really
important that we don't just drink plain
water all the time that they drink some
electrolyte containing fluids just to
drive thirst and help retain some of
those fluids in the muscle where they
need it to do the work in the hydration
aspect we've played is highly
underestimated when we're looking at
their profile of footballers we've got
Olympic sprinters we've got marathon
runners they cover distances of anything
between sort of 10 and 13 kilometers in
the game scattered in there's lots of
Sprint's one of the key determining
factors that we find with players at the
highest level is that ability to perform
those repeated Sprint's on on a regular
basis some of the guys can be having
some pretty decent sweat losses in a
game they might lose like two two kilos
maybe even in the winter when it's cold
when they brought gloves on we've got
like a couple of layers on no sweat
rates are actually quite significant so
hydrations a big focus
[Music]